cancer,
heart disease, lung disease,
renal disease,
dementia --
how did we improve patient experience?
"I want to be at home, Doc."
"OK, we'll bring the care to you."
Quality of life, enhanced.
Think about the human being.
Two: population health.
How did we look at this population differently,
and engage with them at a different level, a deeper level,
and connect to a broader sense of the human condition than my own?
How do we manage this group,
so that of our outpatient population,
94 percent, in 2012, never had to go to the hospital?
Not because they couldn't.
But they didn't have to.
We brought the care to them.
We maintained their value, their quality.
Number three: per capita expenditures.
For this population,
that today is 2.3 trillion dollars and in 20 years is 60 percent of the GDP,
we reduced health care expenditures by nearly 70 percent.
They got more of what they wanted based on their values,
lived better and are living longer,
for two-thirds less money.
While Harold's time was limited,
palliative care's is not.
Palliative care is a paradigm from diagnosis through the end of life.
The hours,
weeks, months, years,
across a continuum --
with treatment, without treatment.
Meet Christine.
Stage III cervical cancer,
so, metastatic cancer that started in her cervix,
spread throughout her body.
She's in her 50s and she is living.
This is not about end of life,
this is about life.
This is not just about the elderly,
this is about people.
This is Richard.
End-stage lung disease.
"Richard, what is it that you hold sacred?"
"My kids, my wife and my Harley."
(Laughter)
"Alright!
I can't drive you around on it because I can barely pedal a bicycle,
but let's see what we can do."
Richard came to me,
and he was in rough shape.
He had this little voice telling him
that maybe his time was weeks to months.
And then we just talked.
And I listened and tried to hear --
big difference.
Use these in proportion to this.
I said, "Alright, let's take it one day at a time,"
like we do in every other chapter of our life.
And we have met Richard where Richard's at day-to-day.
And it's a phone call or two a week,
but he's thriving in the context of end-stage lung disease.
Now, palliative medicine is not just for the elderly,
it is not just for the middle-aged.
It is for everyone.
Meet my friend Jonathan.
We have the honor and pleasure
of Jonathan and his father joining us here today.
Jonathan is in his 20s, and I met him several years ago.
He was dealing with metastatic testicular cancer,
spread to his brain.
He had a stroke,
he had brain surgery,
radiation, chemotherapy.
Upon meeting him and his family,
he was a couple of weeks away from a bone marrow transplant,
and in listening and engaging,
they said, "Help us understand -- what is cancer?"
How did we get this far
without understanding what we're dealing with?
How did we get this far without empowering somebody
to know what it is they're dealing with,
and then taking the next step and engaging in who they are as human beings
to know if that is what we should do?
Lord knows we can do any kind of thing to you.
But should we?
And don't take my word for it.
All the evidence that is related to palliative care these days
demonstrates with absolute certainty people live better and live longer.
There was a seminal article out of the New England Journal of Medicine
in 2010.
A study done at Harvard by friends of mine, colleagues.
End-stage lung cancer:
one group with palliative care,
a similar group without.
The group with palliative care reported less pain,
less depression.
They needed fewer hospitalizations.
And, ladies and gentlemen,
they lived three to six months longer.
If palliative care were a cancer drug,
every cancer doctor on the planet would write a prescription for it.
Why don't they?
Again, because we goofy, long white-coat physicians
are trained and of the mantra of dealing with this,
not with this.
This is a space that we will all come to at some point.
But this conversation today is not about dying,
it is about living.
Living based on our values,
what we find sacred
and how we want to write the chapters of our lives,
whether it's the last
or the last five.
What we know,
what we have proven,
is that this conversation needs to happen today --
not next week, not next year.
What is at stake is our lives today
and the lives of us as we get older
and the lives of our children and our grandchildren.
Not just in that hospital room
or on the couch at home,
but everywhere we go and everything we see.
Palliative medicine is the answer to engage with human beings,
to change the journey that we will all face,
and change it for the better.
To my colleagues,
to my patients,
to my government,
to all human beings,
I ask that we stand and we shout and we demand
the best care possible,
so that we can live better today
and ensure a better life tomorrow.
We need to shift today
so that we can live tomorrow.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)